[Musique]
bonsoir et bien au sommaire ce soir le
show business avec nos invités sur
polaroïd et bien juliette gréco daniel
guichard
aimable
hervé cristiani
un groupe de rock qui s'appelle carte de
séjour et un autre qui s'appelle ffi
andré halimi
patrice blanc francard
pierre perrin le clair de lune à
maubeuge
magali et sophie mais sauf si n'est pas
là et collent pas qu'al poule
journaliste à libération bob ce qu'est
maison de disque dur à laquelle tout à
l'heure peut-être et les dessins ce soir
seront de loups qui nous dit bonjour
déjà et bien voilà et cette émission
bien nous l'avons programmé ce soir
parce que peut-être le savez vous il y à
l'inauguration ce soir du printemps de
bourges par le ministre de la culture
jack lang s'est donc je crois une des
rares fois où un ministre de la culture
s'intéressent à la chanson et semble
vouloir la prendre au sérieux et bien ce
soir nous allons prendre la chanson au
sérieux puisque nous allons mettre le
show-business show business en question
avec nos invités et des professionnels
du disque et des chanteurs il y a les
deux côté de la barricade parce qu'il ya
parfois des barricades dans ce métier je
voudrais signaler donc nous avions
invité des représentants des radios
périphériques ou de certaines grandes
émissions de variétés qui
malheureusement semble tous vouloir
vraiment prendre des vacances car les
vacances de pâques sont pratiquement
commencé c'est un peu de ces îles en
intérêts vous créiez suez gréco oui
alors je ne sais pas s'ils ont intérêt
mais en tout cas nous nous le regrettons
parce qu'évidemment certaine
choses risquent d'être dit qu'il aimait
tant un peu en cause ma nous leur
donnerons un droit de réponse la semaine
prochaine que le pack all poule vous
n'avez pas l'air tellement surpris que
certaines personnes aient refusé de
venir ben non je pense que quand on
parle déjà des gens de radio on pourrait
y ajouter un certain nombre de gens de
télévision parce qu'il n'y a pas
tellement de gens en dehors des gens
d'ici et bon ça aurait été assez amusant
au moins que c'est pas du luxe par
exemple qui va faire paraître un come
back que le triomphant viennent parler
avec mon petit peu ce soir et puis il ya
aussi d'autres gens qui sont pas là et
je pense qu'on peut leur souhaiter bonne
vacances puisqu'ils ont tous les
retraites très encombré parce que d'une
personne les venues des maisons de
disques sauf boxe au quai de versailles
oui nous livre en bavent d'ailleurs tiré
au père de mercy dans les maisons de
disques je parle des grandes maisons de
disques quand même est bon ni alain levy
de cbs ni louis azote polygram ni eddie
barclay de ni bernard de beauce son
double vérone il est mon cabas de vaud
glee alors de
rire vote derniers qui n'ont pu venir ce
soir parce que juste ils sont tous
partis en vacances alors bon je sais pas
j'espère qu'on va essayer de pas trop
parler au mur
en tout cas moi je vais me remettre à ma
place tant pis si je suis dans
l'obscurité parce que vraiment je me
sens très mal là ça va il est en train
de mettre un projecteur l'oeil ils sont
fantastiques
il rattrape tout bon et bien écoutez
je voudrais demander à hervé cristiani
déjà qu'un bon si nous l'avons invité
c'est que c'est un tube sa chanson mac
et esclaves ça sur les ondes ça passe
beaucoup et nous verrons à la prise de
l'enfant qu'elle en juillet c'est un
tube il faut le dire alors dit le est-ce
que c'est un tube sur radio france aussi
sur france inter où il signe de deuil
mais je crois que enfin bon cristiani
sait bien que les chambres depuis un
petit morceau de terre et qu'il faut en
général une chanson qui colle
terriblement à la personnalité de
quelqu'un pour que d'un seul coup ça
s'expose qui s'est passé avec avec max
est ce que vous en avez souffert pendant
longtemps de j'ai quand même fait 4 30
avant celui là 14
4 6 4 6 4
ça veut dire quatre ans de travail
assidu c'est un investissement total
quand on fait comme je lé fais c'est la
musique la réalisation et tout le
bastringue et c'est un investissement de
son corps et de son coeur quand on se
prend une gamelle après avoir donné tout
ce qu'on a dans le ventre ça fait mal ça
fait très mal alors et d'un côté c'est
très enrichissant parce que c'est comme
les dépressions nerveuses quand on en
ressort gagnant sans pilule et sans
cachet tout va bien ça peut être
enrichissant mais il faut pas non plus
que ça dure trop longtemps moi j'ai ramé
pendant mes 6 ans un peu comme tout le
monde c'est normal que
que ça vienne là surtout avec cette
chanson suis très content c'était mon
message je voulais dire ça je suis ravie
je suis un homme heureux et est ce que
est ce que est ce que d'autres sont
malheureux à cause de vous par exemple
est-ce qu'on a l'impression que est ce
que c'est un cas de matraquage max est
ce que ça reste qu est ce qu on pourrait
pas qu'al poule vous croyez que c'est un
matraquage des radios je sais pas si
c'est un matraquage des radios tu m'as
ya certainement une partie de ça
maintenant
on peut pas dire non plus faut pas dire
que parce qu'une chanson marche c'est
obligatoirement une mauvaise chanson
faut pas non plus tout temps de la barre
dans l'autre sens cela dit bon c'est
vrai qu'il ya souvent
ou de plus que le retour des chansons
qu'ils sont
irène la chansonnette au sens très
péjoratif du terme parce que
chansonnette c'est pas forcément
péjoratif il ya quand même une je crois
qu'il ya un envahissement de choses
insipide oui jouer vainqueur il ya
matraquage et matraquage il ya un
matraquage systématique qui se fait sur
un certain nombre de produits merci
serge et béate mars et mai en face c'est
pas ça qui défile c'est fini c'est pas
ça qui fait la tum qui fait un tube
c'est les gens qui achètent eux disent
que dire c'est quand même les gens on ne
force pas acheter le disque on peut le
forcer
les autres quelles raisons on appelle ça
produit on peut les forcer à les contrer
sur le fasse pas beaucoup de questions
je deviens alors dit c'est que cette
âpre est-ce que nous sommes des produits
mis à niveau à partir du moment où vous
avez fait un disque vous avez une très
forte chance d'avoir un certain nombre
de gens considéré ça comme produit
daniel guichard oui oui dans ce bureau
prenant il est je pense de même sony
show business c'est pour les américains
vont passer c'est une expression et non
pas une bonne finition même le mode tu
pètes 1 et un moment tu as une bonne
chanson moi je voudrais pas dire
qu'outre sort de léo ferré est un tube
tu es ce qu'une bonne chanson
non ne convient pas de vos tubes ne sais
pas si les gens téléphonent pierre
perrin quoi sans publicité oui c'était
mon cas 19h55 avant les informations à
un rock numéro un pas de publicité match
à rien lucien morisse mme passe le
disque est entendue les informations
passent 8h30 on appelle personne n'avait
rien demandé et on commence à téléphoner
il entendre au téléphone pour ce
personne n'avait préparé la chose bon
c'était une une avalanche alors pire
paiera puisque vous attendez on va
écouter un petit bout d'une chanson que
les jeunes qui sont là ne doivent pas
connaître parce que ça remonte
maintenant quelques années alors on peut
entendre un petit peu de souvenirs ça
nous enfin
s'appelant un père de l'unam on peut
je
tout ça ne profite pas
le doux soleil de tours points disait
[Musique]
il y avait des canards
voyez alors
pierre moudre à nos fins la mort
des 50 millisecondes à la dernière et
participent et bien présent autant
pierre perrin qu'est ce qui s'est passé
le clair de lune à maubeuge et une
chanson qui pour pas la génération des
onze ans qui sont sur ce plateau mais
pour celles qui en ont 30 aujourd'hui un
tube fabuleux à l'époque et puis depuis
pierre perrin plus rien il a disparu a
fait un grand succès ça prouve bien mais
ça prouve bien que j'aie eu autre chose
non j'ai écrit quinze livres ouais bon
dgg j'ai participé au mercure de france
j'ai participé à un tas de choses je
n'ai pas fait au clair de lune à
maubeuge on me donne une étiquette je
n'ai que le clair de lune mais il ya
autre chose si vous venez chez moi je
vous ai donné une documentation pour moi
c'est très secondaire le clair de lune
mais voilà ce que je voulais c'était une
chance pour moi j'ai fait autrement
autre chose reste noir de droits
d'auteur quand même mais je suppose que
les droits d'auteur et axa se vend
encore je vous dis trente mille disques
à la dernière partie de sa part demandé
les choses à dire là dessus c'est très
curieux manu c'est emmanuel beauce est
un groupe de rock ouï manu ffi et que je
dois dire je voudrais dire je voudrais
dire aux gens qu'on est là pour parler
du show business oui des pratiques du
showbiz et non pas des carrières
personnelles de chacun bon d'accord
alors dans l'industrie
d'accord
[Musique]
mais je voulais quitter quand même
quelques exemples en début d'émission
qui était d'exemple côté frappant est un
autre exemple est parmi nous cet aimable
aimable vous alors vous n'êtes pas un
homme du show biz vous existez gars je
voulais comme ça et voilà moi je voulais
demander à hervé s'il y avait un
accordéoniste qui avait enregistré max
parce que quand un accordéoniste
enregistre un succès d'une chanteuse ou
d'un chanteur ont fait descendre la
chanson dans la rue on l'a fait
connaître à tout le monde parce qu
est-ce qui fait un tube ce qui fait un
succès que c'est que les gens le cif la
chanson chante la chanson c'est là que
vous avez le tube pardon est ce que
c'est mais il ya un autre homme garde de
séjour il faudrait que ça chante dans
l'art est ce que vous chantez dans la
rue j'aimerais vous voir au moins quand
j'ai un morceau que j'aime bien par
exemple siffler la danse des canards
temps en temps dans la rue c'est ça je
ne sais jamais du moins ne s'est jamais
vu jouer la sphère première fois que je
vous vois dans l'alabama
et moi d'autres jeunes qui ça fait ça
fait trente ans que je me fais le métier
ça fait trente ans que je suis dans une
maison de disques et en 30 ans
j'enregistrais wimille titres de
chansons différents nous avait fait
combien de disques d'or puisque j'en ai
7,7 je parie qu'on ne parlait pas dessus
revenons mots c'est amusant patate mais
et dites moi alors d'autres cas ça
prouverait finalement que le matraquage
le showbiz les émissions dans tout ça ça
vous sert pas vous cache quand on passe
dans une émission avec une autre amie
qui luttent 1 on passe à dix
l'accordéoniste on a toujours envie de
nous prendre nous la preuve quand on
joue de l'accordéon ont nourri du scot
sur la marque
bon et alors moi j'ai l'impression
aimable que avant même de parler de
cette espèce de show biz qui a une
espèce de deux choses un petit peu
américanisé tous accueilli la france
profonde elle est restée à la chanson
d'avant-guerre à l'accordéon et vous
jouez quoi ce soir par exemple d'aller
nous quitter en vitesse pour aller avec
votre hélicoptère non les gars là
je fais une balle tout à l'heure à la
ferté gaucher mes musiciens ils
attaquent à 9 heures et moi je serai là
bas disposent me demande encore des
choses comme par exemple je vous le cite
l'exemple la java bleue parce que j'ai
été frappée j'étais à venise l'année
dernière mon voyage la flotte française
et il y avait tous ces marins et on se
croyait dans un film de carnets parce
qu'ils sont arrivés à dix heures du soir
à rentrer à aubord dans un état que je
n'imaginais pas vous imaginer première
caisse qui chantait pas un tube
d'aujourd'hui il chantait la java bleue
bon et je trouve que c'est assez
frappant de voir que malgré tout ce que
feront les radios périphériques et la
télé il ya toujours cette tradition qui
continue de la cause de l'état du marin
c'est l'état des marins on pouvait pas
l'écouter java bleue mais mal puisqu'il
sait son accordéon c'est un peu
[Musique]
et
bah voila voila faber
ya quelqu'un ici qui a l'air absolument
ravie de vous entendre c'est madame
molinier madame au lycée rabelais ya
longtemps maintenant je le suis oui oh
oui chaque centre genevois la télévision
où je suis quelque part j'essaie vous il
y est j'y vais est ce que vous trouvez
qu'on entend assez ce genre de musique à
l'année en plastique pas assez face à
ces cueilleurs d'autres pourquoi qui a
été est fabien l'accordéon tous les
samedis à 1h30 pour nous il a su connais
mais c'est pourquoi c'était quelque
chose
alors ne le passe à une autre mais là
c'est une autre île face à 11 heures du
matin le samedi 11 ans vous voyez tout
ce que vous allez adorer télévision à
regarder non il faut pas pousser quand
même nom mais
qui sort
surtout madame pauline et je redonnerai
la page y en avoir rarement à la
télévision sur ces pour laquelle edward
et bella pourquoi alors pourquoi elle va
nous le dire le voyageur pourquoi c'est
le sujet de l'émission voyage alors je
vous donnerai la parole tout à l'heure
parce que j'ai des choses à dire sur les
samedis après midi encore cet après midi
je vous assure j'ai fait ma télé
[Applaudissements]
c'est le rock'n'roll qui vous déplaît
c'est ça
il faut changer alors voilà et un chef
non je vous remercie on me l'a dit ça
trois chalets lors elles sont moches
madame il ya des milliers madame ollier
oui malheureusement n'y a pas une seule
fois il en faut une démarche place aux
jeunes
madame olivier justement je crois que
c'est ça vous avez écrit pour protester
très violemment
et aussi en argentine
oui les lauragais vous avez eu la nette
elle n'est pas méchante la led qui vous
dit qu'il faut les émissions pour les
jeunes mais le bas de la lettre vous
l'avez lu elle m'a pas frappé
oui
l'année daniel guichard que vous aimez
bien madame ohlins pense qu'il faut pas
être daniel guichard faudrait arrêter
d'être correct parce qu'on va tourner
cette dame on dirige pas du tout normal
on est motivés pas de mauvaise humeur
mais je lis le papier droit de réponse
avec les invités et je vois mal un
molinier personnages et réac alors ils
ont rien désolé non cf il assez fou
qu'il arrive et c'est donc non non je
suis désolé dames pour la tournée en
ridicule nancy voulait parler du
show-business parlons-en le débat de
cette manière voilà c'est par lors du
show biz
shopping en ligne et essayer pas de vous
amuser ou aux dépens du placement ni à
la télévision parce qu'on est à pleurer
s'amuse pas du tout répond à ces
questions quand même
sur la deuxième vague a surpassé pas si
j'ai pas le rush sur la première que les
gars rien fait en tout cas vous avez
droit à la parole le nouveau mot co2
moquons pas du tout madrid tient pas du
tout je trouve qu'elle a un don de
répartir remarquable les jeux wii mais
vont tomber dans un traquenard pas du
tout je voudrais convient d'abord de
parler un peu de
on
rapporte andré halimi je voudrais
prendre un petit peu de la chanson
française la chanson française est
malade du show business
la chanson française est née grâce à
deux grands auteurs compositeurs
interprètes depuis mireille jean nohain
charles trenet brassens béart gainsbourg
ferré cabrel guichard et beaucoup
d'autres et je pense qu'une souche ans
et beaucoup d'envié
bon on a eu une chance de très bonne
qualité à côté de ça nous avons eu des
analphabètes qui se sont emparés de la
chanson par le fric par le biais du
matraquage en s'emparant des maisons de
disques parce que je trouve vraiment
très choquant que certaines radios
périphériques ont des maisons de disques
c'est à dire que c'est vraiment la
concertation au total on fabrique des
maîtres des disques et on les passe dans
un sur sa chaîne alors ça c'est ça me
paraît choquant et révoltant la même
façon qu'on sait par certaines grosses
maisons aussi les mains on doit en faire
autant pour la chanson ensuite la
chanson française souffre d'autres
choses du désintérêt des grands de ce
monde quand boris vian écrit son livre
la chanson eh bien on s'est intéressé à
16h02 la chanson on s'en moque et parce
que c'est la chanson ont fait c'est la
magouille on laisse un petit jean autres
étant on s'en fout tous les jours il ya
des jeunes qui lui des chansons et qu'il
ne s'agit pas d'autres genres on se
moque des chansons soient pillés on se
voit que les chansons soient plagié ça
on s'est vraiment la magouille des
petites jambes c'est vraiment le règne
de l'argent avec lui ce qu'il a de plus
trapu le alors à partir de là le showbiz
est là et il est ensemble milieu de ces
son poisson qui s'en empare il crée ses
propres ses propres contradictions
d'ailleurs il a ses journaux l'as et
radio il a cité les émissions il à ces
gens il a cédé sous table tous assez on
n'en sortira jamais de malades du
showbiz et à ba2 de la cantine quand
auteur compositeur qui sort mais il faut
applaudir mais il y en a qui sort tous
les deux ans moi je me donne à ce brave
aux souches à bravo et quand il ya des
interprètes au musée djetou qui chante
ferré et brassens bravo
oui bravo si vous n'avez pas du tout
déjà je suis désolé bravo pour la vigne
et mais j'ai pas dit je suis désolée je
lis ou changer dit jonage positif à
sarcelles
attendez que philippe constantin vous
avez pris la parole vous avez une maison
de dix appels virgin c'est une petite
maison par ailleurs
si pardon excusez moi fils constanta
vous êtes éditeur et c'est thierry o pki
et virgin pardon d'accord vous êtes de
nous voir ensemble voilà je vous ai
confondu philippe constantin vous vous
êtes d'accord aussi avec ce que dit
andré halimi c'est à dire que non non
non je crois pas que la création ce soir
était effectivement il ya six mois la
rétine non mais je parie qu'elle s'était
arrêtée il ya des exemples extrêmement
grave prenons il ya des exemples
extrêmement grave oui où on enfin
jéricho d'ailleurs il faudra qu'elle
réponde à madame ollier il lui a posé
une page absolument la création et on
stoppe la création pendant des années
ils avaient exemple on peut prendre
l'exemple d'un homme comme comme maurice
manon qui était qui est un type
extraordinaire bon qui est vraiment un
grand un grand écrivain cette dame est
c'est été stoppés pour des raisons de
procès entre la maison barclay et la
maison polydor ou une chose comme celle
là je pense je crois je crois me
rappeler mes lunettes
non et c'est cette table est resté
quatre ans bridée et pendant dix ans cet
homme n'a pas pu faire un disque
alors
de quoi avons-nous l'air est-ce que nous
sommes des hommes est-ce que nous sommes
des humains est-ce que nous sommes des
gens normaux
est ce que nous acceptons ce qui nous
est propre à faire le gangstérisme des
producteurs bon alors on va
sourit daniel guichard je vais pas faire
un grand numéro mais là le problème par
exemple de maurice calendes c'est le
problème de tous les artistes ont fait
tous les champs de la terre non je vais
jeter et l'élargir avenches et bien que
les champions sont ces accords annoncés
parce que les créateurs sont
relativement protégés par la loi puisque
les auteurs elle de 57 elle protège les
auteurs et éditeurs en personne n'en
veut personne n'en veut mais les
chanteurs il existe une petite lacune
dans la loi qui fait que la voix n'est
pas reconnu comme étant quelque chose de
personnel c'est à dire on reconnaît par
la voix d'edith piaf c'est que ça n'est
qu'un artiste et à partir de ce moment
là quand un artiste se trouve en procès
c'est ce qui se passe pour feindre c'est
ce qui s'est passé pour beaucoup
d'artistes ils sont purement et
simplement cassé c'est brel qui avait
dit et c'est brel qui avait dit à
barclay il faut il faut prendre enfin
non parce que fanon il est formidable
parce que brel était quelqu'un
d'extraordinairement généreux don comme
comme chacun sait n'est pas on n'est pas
là pour faire le générique des gens mais
simplement pour dire la vérité et
tout à coup fanon se trouver face aux
multinationales
et mettez la semaine ce n'est pas de
l'identité ça s'appelle des
multinationales et il a été entièrement
coin c'est foutu
crown est un compositeur une vraie
cristiani oui un auteur compositeur je
crois doit être en dehors de ça un
auteur compositeur c'est un émetteur
récepteur ils disent qu'il reçoit il
s'occupe pas de ces choses-là 1 quel
triomphe on peut pas pendant quatre ans
pas leur chance on and on fait des
chansons et quand on fait des chansons
que personnel de au registre qu'est-ce
que ça s'arrête ça fait rien ça fait un
bien meilleur jusqu'à ce que les gens
cèdent à corps et se prosternent est
d'aider mes récits et peut-être n'y a
déjà pas d'énerver crd souffre faire une
chanson c'est souffrir c'est à descendre
ou prendre soi-même pour aller donner le
meilleur de soi même si on est le sort
semble d'accord ça fait trois ans que je
fais ce métier mais eh bien il faut
savoir il faut savoir assumer à nous
traverser du désert même si elle dure
dix ans on doit faire nos chansons on
s'occupe du reste ces débrayages j'ai 33
ans je vais large et j'ai quand même eu
le temps de souffrir un petit peu dans
mon métier je vais déjà j'espère aussi
j'ai toujours considéré que leur seul
moyen de me tirer d'affaires c'était de
créer de créer c'est la seule joie qui
nous qui nous est qui nous est propre à
nous les auteurs compositeurs c'est
mieux que de la connaissez mieux qu'un
tube de faire une chanson pour soi quand
elle est finie on a fini à 6 dany boon
on est content c'est important dans sa
chanson chacun son plaisir possible si
on veut pas l'enregistrer en or fait une
autre il ya toujours un moment où
la galilée n'est pas tellement de la vie
d'harry cristiani mais avant avant je
voudrais tout de même puisqu'on évoque
maurice fanon attendre un petit peu en
écho juliette gréco qui chante une
chanson de maurice fanon là oui je crois
qu'on a ça quelque part derrière vous
pour ceux qui entrent dans la danse afro
ou non de la danse
au mépris des vies monfils chambre
pour ceux qui luttent pour la vie sans
autre arme que revive pour qu'il vive
jean bonfils champ
pour ceux qui combattent la nuit pour le
jour où le sera élu ra pour tous les
âges monfils ocha
je ne sais pas je vois bien peyrens
s'agite beaucoup vous avez une lettre à
la main qu'est ce que ça fait là j'y
rentre dans une société très connue tant
pis pour moi si j'ai un procès je rentre
chez pathé marconi oui il y en ait
enregistré chez ricordi bien me trouvant
ricordi partant dans son pays la chan et
abandonnant tout je me trouve récupéré
par pathé marconi alors comme si tu
avais recommandé du 24 novembre nous
voyons pas d'homme sage quelques vous ré
enregistré pour un tiers les oeuvres que
vous avez cités
nous tenons cependant à préciser que la
présente autorisation de ré
enregistrement ne saurait concerner le
titre terre de lune à maubeuge qui
figure actuellement à notre catalogue il
ya eu des radios périphériques on
demande mon titre on ne le trouve nul
passe chez aucun disquaires aucun
distributeur les gens vont toutes les
radios pirates vous chez pathé marconi
qui demandent mon 10
avec son restera plus
alors
je suis d'accord quoi ma tout un tir dit
merci pierre perrin votre exemple est
bon il y en a d'autres à citer à l'eau
je crois qu'il est bon
un
débat qui collent pas paul poulx je
pense qu'il faudra un petit peu sortir
du misérabilisme d'une discours un peu
misérabilisme et de l'éloge de la
souffrance moi je sais pas ça
m'intéresse pas beaucoup par contrat et
des mois attend pas d'accord mais je
pense qu'il ya quand même quelque chose
qu'il faut dire là où il ya une
à
un fils de fois ravi de fonctionnement
des des multinationales en général c'est
que en ce qui concerne surtout une
génération qui est plus une génération
la mienne plus une génération de la
nôtre c'est à dire des gens qui sont nés
avec le rock en quelque sorte c'est que
cette musique pendant longtemps elle a
été complètement marginalisé dans
l'autre sens et que l achat elle
trouvait toujours de quoi tourner elle
trouvait toujours de quoi se montrer
dans les concerts bon ils ont que plus d
a plus facilement mais en tout cas en ce
qui concerne les disques ça a été des
années d aléria dé voir le cas d'higelin
par exemple bon tout le monde est là
quoi prenant recensés aujourd'hui bon
monsieur que lui a jamais fonctionné sur
le mode de la souffrance et de faut
souffrir bon bah c'est vrai qu'il faut
batailler mais je pense que c'est aussi
une des choses de ce métier je pense que
par contre les maisons de disques elles
ont loupé deux coaches trois coches
avant de rentrer là dedans et ça c'est
ça c'est ça c'est un grave problème
moore cch je voudrais vous citer un
exemple avant qu'on parle des problèmes
du rock et il lui a encore d'après
l'exemple de pierre perrin un exemple
assez extraordinaire je dois dire que je
voudrais qu'on évoque tout de suite
avant de continuer le débat pour rester
encore dans les cas particuliers
c'est magali qui hélas à sa soeur sophie
sa soeur jumelle n'est pas là parce que
je crois que les journaux l'ont annoncé
est ce que vous pouvez nous dire
pourquoi votre jumelle voilà la fin de
tentatives de suicide dimanche soir donc
je reviens à ce que disait marc gréco je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec elle
quand on est jeune et qu'on nous promet
beaucoup de choses qu'on rende compte
qu'on nous lance dans la chanson comme
ça on n'y connaît rien donc on croit à
ce que les gens nous dit nous donc j'ai
raconté de financer s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît tout le monde ne parle pas en
même temps laisser me magali raconter
son histoire section dans une école de
danse à l'académie de danse toute la
journée le vieux que l'homme nous avions
16 ans et demi jean paul cara chercher
deux jumelles pour l'eurovision qui est
jean paul quin jean-paul cajas il a
écrit beaucoup de chansons pour leur
vision marignane il a écrit l'oiseau et
l'enfant catherine fait rien de toi
il est donc arrivé dans cette école de
danse et les plusieurs je veux pas dire
par deux jumelles plusieurs jumelles
qu'il était là il nous a choisis on a
fait des maquettes qui a été proposé rtl
qui a été acceptée on s'est retrouvé sur
la scène de l'eurovision
ça très très bien marché c'est ce qu'on
dit un tube ça a été un tube oui on va
l'écouter tout de suite là pour qu'on
vous situe bien et ce tube i date de
1981 l'eurovision les antilles et le
luxembourg peut l'écouter ce tube un
petit peu on le situe
[Musique]
tout va bien
voilà ça c'est une chanson qui a eu un
succès à fait que de considérables si
vous en avez vendu combien 160 me il
fait beaucoup rire nos enfants là c'est
pas le genre de chansons qu'ils aiment
non si ça vous plaît vous avez ri parce
que ça vous plaise ou pas ce que ça vous
plaît pas on saura par les autres
candidats
pourquoi tu arrives un sens pas le dire
enfin voilà bon alors racontez nous
parce que l'histoire n'est pas aussi
drôle ans damien quelle que soit la
qualité ou allan théo vendu beaucoup
beaucoup disent et avec ça on a fait
toutes les télés possible les rares tels
abois a suivi puisqu'il était co éditeur
et donc c'est un producteur on attendait
ça s'est passé en allemagne on a signé
un contrat
les canes allemand qui s'appellera
siegel ensuite pour le deuxième disque
qui s'est plus occupés nous il y avait
aucune promotion rien du tout alors avec
sophie on a dit on a revendu les
contrats et on va voir ailleurs et râle
siegel nous a fait un procès on a été
condamné à six semaines de prison je dis
bien six semaines de prison et 155
millions de dommages et intérêts
il a ni l'autre le problème c'est que
les problèmes des contrats et ont donc
on paye des avocats pourtant nous
défendre
fonctionne nous aveugler loyalty bel et
bien sûr on a sorti qu'à disque
d'ailleurs j'en profite à fonctionner
dans des fermes à promotion pas trop pas
trop parce que si chacun fait sa
promotion à laquelle ce dernier
s'est fait raconter c'est que vous aviez
17 ans on vous a tout d'un coup propulsé
on a mis dans une belle robe son ami des
bdd très belle robe on vous a mis sous
les projecteurs
tout à fait c'est un peu du côté de moi
je dis que c'est du proxénétisme et
bastos fait
marcher
ça marche et ça marche flux obtiendra le
single est un proxénète
quand on prend quand on vend 850 mille
disques on prend assez d'argent et quand
on refuse de payer les royals qui est un
artiste alors là tous les artistes en
droit d'être d'être payés mais là il
prend non seulement une paye pas les
royalties mais en plus il est des
attaques de 150 millions si sophie
magali avec monsieur barkoff jean pierre
jean paul martin qui est le meilleur
attaché de presse enfin le disque les
les autres discours ce genre de marché
l'oreille monsieur lederman comme
producteur le disque aurait marché des
applis radios libres qui passe mon
disque part ça je dis bravo radio lille
je m'avance que tête non ce que vous
voulez dire pour ne pas relancer ne
réduiront pas trop dans les détails ce
qui est intéressant dans votre histoire
ce qui est intéressant dans votre
histoire c'est que finalement vous a
fait miroiter une carrière ce n'est
qu'en réalité ils avaient l'intention de
lancer un disque à l'eurovision ça lui
rapporter comme ça beaucoup d'argent et
ensuite il vous a laissé tomber par
certaines opérations sur un tuyau et
vont naïve vous aviez signé une
exclusivité wii s'est très souvent en
juillet dont 80 des groupes de rock à
qui sa
fin de contrat avec charles tall ah oui
et donc j'en paie le plus gentil il
saisit le disque à chaque fois j'invite
à peu de fans non mais sur un autre
oui
on a enregistré 2000 45 tours qu'est ce
qu'il en reste je lisais le livre de
leproux sur le golf drouot il a reçu 800
groupes testing en reste tous ces gens
qui chantent aujourd'hui un 45 tours qui
ne chante plus à après qui va chanter
dans 10 ans ou dans vingt ans dans la
musique quand ils font un disque on se
connaît même pas leurs visages moi j'en
ta chanson chagrin d'amour je sais même
pas qui la chante 700 la radio mais que
ces gens soient capables d'aller sur
scène
parce que c'est l'utilisation de la
chanson chaleur industrie
la chanson c'est aussi navigateur c'est
ça que je suis un spectacle s'est passé
à bord l'utilisation de voix qui sont
même pas les leurs excusez moi il ya des
gens qui ont chanté avec avec une
chanson qui n'était pas la leur jacynthe
cloutier d'utiliser plus facilement
fondé de music hall et de la randonnée
ce qu'entend calmer les tensions ligne
maintenant c'est pas les grands plats
chez nous et non pas du tout
silence s'il vous plaît
bon alors moi je voudrais dire aux gens
que le tout les problèmes particuliers
qui sont ici sont liées au showbiz alors
qu'est ce que c'est que le shopping
voilà je prends le rer
le showbiz show spectacle de variétés
centré sur une valve est business
travail à faire embrouiller un truc
qu'une chose donc il est bien évident
que si le cda perd embrouillé on ne
serait jamais contents ils vont toujours
vous piéger alors en france de shawville
je vais vous dire il n'existe pas
lorsqu'on n'a même pas trouvé un nom
français pour le définir c'est un air
daft de kobe pour comme ça ça c'est la
déclaration cocardières façon 14-18
essaie de prouver quelque chose un peu
moins
sept jours nous parle
et qu'on est allés saluer les avons
remis les médailles
des urgences que c'est que le show man u
terme le showbiz
en france parce qu on sait quand même
que les on chasse ou ce qui se passe ici
a débuté par des gens qui ont monté les
maisons c'était des petits artisans
c'était des artistes qui ont monté les
maisons du show-business au départ
ensuite elles ont été prises en main par
des avocats et maintenant par le
marketing bon ça veut dire que c'est
devenu des holdings et tous les gens et
des multinationales et tous les gens qui
rentrent dans ce système ne peuvent être
que les produits et les gens qui sont
ici ne sont que des employés et il est
regrettable que les pdg des holdings que
ça soit siemens pour polygram ne soit
pas ici car ces gens là n'ont rien à
[ __ ] de la rien et de la chanson ils
sont là pour faire des millions et de
l'argent sur le dos de gens qui sont
généreux et qui viennent donner leur
argent -
[Applaudissements]
dont la réponse d'abord eu le courage de
venir
non mais je m'arrange mois d'août et je
ne suis pas déçu du tout bas je trouve
qu'elle approche de manu est pas et pas
mal moi je suis le premier à dire je
suis dans une société c'est vrai
multinationales et c'est vrai que je
cherche à faire le plus de profit
possible je m'engage pas du tout
j'investis ont peu près 1 milliards
d'anciens francs par an pour enregistrer
les gens j'ai enregistré l'année
dernière je vous parlais trop cheap mais
pour le savoir quand même 381 titres en
français jr bon j'ai l'impression de
participer quelque part quand même à la
création que de ça comme l'y monsieur
halimi il ne reste rien qu'est ce qui
reste aussi dans le livre qu'est-ce qui
reste aussi dans le cinéma je dirais que
demandent les parallèles et ses lions
mais c'est vrai que la parole michel
estevan était d'abord l'assimilation et
je suis complètement d'accord avec
monsieur blanc francard aussi
assignation dans le music hall et le
dise pourquoi la faire systématiquement
va se caler pas elle est plus vrai et je
vois pas pourquoi c'est plus mal qu'elle
soit plus vrai et bien jugement de
valeur que je refuse aussi pourquoi dire
quant à nice que marche c'est parce que
c'est de la merde c'est pas vrai on
appose jamais quelque chose à quelqu'un
et on ne va pas jouer
laissez moi finir je vous ai sélectionné
en fait on en pourra les acheter c'est
toute une démarche est une c'est faux
l'échelle disques fc cialis faut mettre
beaucoup d'argent il faut aller chez soi
faut l'écouter chez william landa l'on
n'avait songé cendres et gilles chaillet
corée c'est à dire y'a plein de choses
comme ça faut pas trop schématiser non
plus alors c'est vrai que le problème
dont on va parler parce que c'est le sol
comment montrer aux gens ce que les
artistes font voilà le coeur du problème
une fois qu'on aura risque de résolu ça
c'est à dire est-ce qu'il faut plus de
radio je suis ravie en a beaucoup plus
est-ce qu'il faut que les radios soient
thématique c'est bien qu'on ait des
radios rock and roll qu'on a des radios
accordéon pour monsieur et ma con et
radios locales pour le ceux qui chargent
je suis tout à fait pour qu'on ouvre
l'éventail que les gens qui est choisir
mais point final le show business il
s'était rempli c'est l'expression je
déteste le show-business c'était que
d'amagou il ya longtemps qu'on a tous
fait faillite constat pas là pour en
parler
d'accord c'est la collection une seconde
s'il vous plaît non ne venait pas
intervenu quand vous n'avez pas de
micros je vous en prie je voudrais au ta
gueule non non écouter
c'est pas la peine on vous attendait ou
alors moi je michel algay voudrait la
parole quant au prix du chien qu'on fait
tout doux nom vous d'accord 1 on fait
une émission à main alors tout doux nom
si vous voyez gentil joaillier allez
vous remettre à la place là bas parmi
les spectateurs
non ce gentil d'aller là bas vous met là
bas s'il vous plaît michel algay vous
êtes tourneur sachet de léo ferré c'est
ça mais depuis c'est pas de l'est où je
pourrais parler mais depuis quarante
minutes que l'émission a commencé vous
oubliez qu'il ya des gens qui vous
regardent et que ce sont eux qui
achètent les disques et que vous ne
faites une petite histoire entre vous
deux maisons de disques d'artistes faut
pas oublier que c'est le public qui fait
les artistes les gens c'est le public et
que j'ai des chiffres la figure vous
avez alors ça y est tu peux les
critiques sa routine me tuer veuillez le
faire alors que gaston toi arrête de les
sortir s'il vous
voyez demandé à monsieur de sortir du
plateau il n'était pas invité en plus
payer soyez gentils demande à monsieur
de sortir du plateau bon alors soyez
gentils allez messieurs sortez vous
n'étiez pas invité je vous ai demandé
l'heure pas bon vous n'étiez pas invité
je vais être obligé de demander au père
sortir c'est pas très agréable alors oui
c'est ça vous l'aurez d'accord je suis
d'accord mais
alors s'il vous plaît veuillez demandé
aux responsables de demander à monsieur
de sortir il un rush peut aller très
bien aller boire un verre d'eau
moi j'aimerais j'aimerais bien parce que
je suis un moment une seconde allant
depuis un moment moi je vais intervenir
parce que je trouve je trouve un peu
stupide le le chemin dans lequel on s'en
bat oui thierry opd disque virgin
prochain on est en train de dire voilà
le showbiz les gens du showbiz sont
d'affreux ordures ya pas de définition
pour le mot showbiz moi j'en ai une le
show biz est un milieu qui correspond et
qui ressemble de manière un jeu
sociologico politique à l'ensemble des
structures qui font que la france est la
france dans ce moment avec le bon air
des contradictions dans laquelle allait
il y a des ordures il ya des gens très
bien qui fait de faire leur métier le
plus correctement du monde et la
majorité des gens qui travaillent dans
le show business comme on dit c'est dire
les employés les attachés de presse
dimanche et qui sont jetés dans les
radios parce qu'elles ont un bon produit
un artiste avec lequel a donc plus que
des liens de travail mais aussi des
liens d'amitié et bien ces gens là il
roule en rire 5 il habite à f2i grâce à
ce stade par mois il travaille c'est une
cheville c'est pas simplement le départ
m
alors qu'attendez alors qu'il erre des
contradictions ensuite avec des holdings
et des grosses multinationales
c'est vrai il y à des multinationales il
y a aussi de plus petites structures qui
essaye de faire un travail donné dans un
ordre donné avec des types de musiques
de l'est qui peuvent aller je suis pas
moi je travaille plutôt sur le
rock'n'roll et des gens qui travaillent
plutôt sur la chanson dite française
j'estime que c'est tout à fait
respectable via différents goûts les
phénomènes de censure qui régissent la
pas la publication de ces musiques sur
les ondes ou à la télévision c'est une
autre paire de manches là le showbiz et
intervient parce qu'il ne se limite pas
aux gens des maisons de disques le
showbiz c'est les journalistes c'est
michel drucker se passe en ce moment sur
l'autre chaîne et qui parce qu'ils
équipent pourquoi cela plutôt que
d'autres c'est n'importe quoi c'est la
politique c'est le hit parade des gens
qu'on nous fait subir ce que vous
préférez une tartine de jacques chirac
ou de michel rocard pour moi si c'est la
même chose bon mais alors écouter et là
bon vous parler par exemple de duy
parade nous avons quelqu'un qui nous a
demandé de venir témoigner c'est
jean-marie ployer daniel guichard le
connais bien je crois qu'ils le
distribuent jean-marie ployer vous êtes
arrivé une petite aventure à propos de
ces fameux vide par adulte précisé pour
que les choses soient claires que cette
aventure nous est arrivé à votre groupe
le groupe bat voilà je supporte parole
du groupe les octaves ça nous est arrivé
il y a à peu près trois ans donc s'est
montré très récent a fait rien on avait
fait à l'époque un disque pour enfants
qui s'appelle qui s'appelle toujours un
enfant dans les sables et rtl télévision
c'est à dire au grand duché nous a
demandé de venir enregistrer une série
de dix ou douze émissions pour les
enfants le mercredi après midi bien
pour cet enregistrement on devait
toucher un cachet de 6000 francs on fait
notre boulot bien sûr le mieux possible
et on entend passer à la caisse le
producteur rtl qui nous avait proposé
l'émission nous dit vous avez le choix
entre le chèque de 6000 francs et la 20e
place au hit parade d'andré torrent
c'est ça qu'on nous a proposé il ya
trois ans et demi à rtl je peux en
témoigner alors je suis venu pour ça je
pensais que c'était important de le
savoir oui alors il est évident que et
dans l'écho part du principe que on doit
être payé pour chanter pour l' inverse
on april chèque de 6000 francs
j'ai pris six mille français plus yeux
et vous n'avez jamais lui a depuis on
n'a plus aucune nouvelle dit parra dont
la la j'ai côtoyé non mais dites moi
vous ne craignez pas de nous aimer
passer rtl non plus maintenant on est
jamais pensé leur talent
daniel dissard ça vous est arrivé ce
genre d' aventure
way le ils paradent en vente personne ne
nous tous cas on parle de show-business
on parle de chansons à personne n'est
dupe où la manière et man non c'est il
faut prendre les choses telles qu'elles
sont on fait ce métier à la base pour
être aimé pour être riche pour être
célèbre pour son 12ème et qu'on
reconnaisse dans la rue ne mentons pas
je suis sûr que les dégâts qui sont la
coupe d'europe qu'ils ont envie d'être
célèbres dont le faire ils ont envie de
faire la musique qu'ils aiment monsieur
pierre perrin chantait la chanson qu'il
aimait nous c'est pareil non certains
réussissent tout pas c'est aussi un peu
la règle et son public le droit c'est
son droit le droit au public de choisir
ce qu'ils aiment ou pas et je suis pas
tout à fait d'accord avec nous sur blanc
francard en disant qu'on est un peu
alors c'est une forme de liberté
d'expression
d'accord d'accord public dans la série
mais si ça te fait plaisir de penser
pense le bon c'est ton droit le plus
absolu de bassecourt hume à l'espagne
mais tu vis ta vie moi je vis la mienne
alors laisse les causes et tu as raison
mais la mienne me plaît bien
monsieur blanc francard d'être laissés
par les daniel guichard blé un petit peu
cocardier je pense que quand on est
français le minimum c'est d'être un
petit peu cocardier eux c'est pas parce
que oui je crois que c'est un minimum de
de droits non un petit peu je sais je
sais que d'ailleurs c'est à une chose
qui m'étonne il semble que jamais ce qui
me regarde pas mais en fait tu es un
spécialiste du rock'n'roll et longueau
500 particuliers et une responsable des
programmes pour le public français qui
en majorité ne parle pas l'anglais
c'était une parenthèse c'est qu'elles
étaient 40 enfin je parlerai là dessus
avec un perso je préfère que vous
préparez vous à la chaire d'histoire
les dédales effectivement il existe des
éditions dans les radios périphériques
et maintenant il paraîtrait que dans
certaines radios modulation de fréquence
il est de bon ton de coéditer certaines
chansons de façon est un peu matraque et
parce que les radios périphériques ne
veulent pas aller passer enfin ça c'est
tout c'est tout je prenais sait et c'est
tout un tas séoul et c'est tout un tas
de combines qui en fait ne vole pas haut
parce que lorsqu'une chanson doit
marcher ce qui est le cas de d'hervé
enfin quand une chanson évident elle
marche
enfin je vous signale quand même pour
compléter la formation de monsieur saïd
que le sénat en 1900 en 1978 est donc
déjà 4 ans a publié un rapport de
monsieur henri cavallier caille avec et
sénateurs centristes je crois et qui est
assez drôle qui est très bien écrit dans
lequel il dit entre autres que le
hit-parade complète la tricherie du
matraquage et que les radios invite les
auditeurs à écrire mais qu'une étude de
la sofres montre que 93% des jeunes
n'ont jamais écrits ou téléphoner pour
un hit parade bref il suffit de payer
pour figurer en tête du hit parade c'est
un sénateur qui a écrit sa les jeunes
vous avez écrite japon hit parade non
oui va répondre avec l'histoire dans les
phonèmes hamel avait donné qu'il fallait
ou aux hits parades n'ont pas l'air de
connaître le paradis
quand même chose c'est regrette patrice
blanc francard et que personne ne peut y
répondre allemand parce que
les parades sont faits sur des stations
commerciales du sang était l europe mais
aussi en rade et monte car il est
regrettable que personne ne puisse
répondre à cette question après question
fondamentale bien sûr si je peux me
permettre l'incidence du hit parade au
niveau de la vente enfin pour n'importe
quel artiste c'est que
il faut simplement regarder le public
les publics qui écoutent la radio entre
4h et 8h c'est un public et ce qui situe
entre 12 ans les vingt ans donc un
public dynamique qui lorsqu'il veut une
chanson va la chercher où elle se trouve
alors que
tu as vécu pendant des années je
comprends pas oui assez souvent en
voyage
avec moi je vais vous dire je considère
que les chansons comme mon vieux où la
tendresse ou faut pas pleurer j'ai pas
en rougir du tout non monsieur cogneur
ce qu'il veut j'en suis plutôt fier ici
ça a été classée au hit parade et bah
j'en suis très fort et là ça a été
curieusement que la cena il ment il
parle parce que c'était des bonnes
chansons est bon alors et alors non
c'est ça c'est la question que je pose
surtout la question même somme que je
sais bien que ça ira je sais qu'on a su
le faire a été classé pendant des mois
numéro un en même temps que les beatles
avec jean n'a pas choqué
est ce que je peux dire que monsieur
ferrat en quelque chose comme 20 ans on
n'est jamais passé à samedi soir
s'annonce une fois avec michel dans
qu'est ce qu'il a fait est ce que je
peux dire ça l'oubli la maison dit dans
laquelle il est aussi
à bon qui s'appelle az distribuer c'est
bien ça avait hélas hélas accord avec
numéros europe numéro un mais là aussi
gérard mèche qui se démène avec +1 point
léo ferré nous rendra trop dans les
détails pour expliquer pourquoi on vous
parlait de radio c'est vrai que az
distribuer les disques de gérard mey et
que high z mais m mm e y excusez moi
c'est votre dario ses surnoms un copain
à moi mais revint à distribuer ces mêmes
titres distribués les titres et ça
faisait partie d'un accord de
distribution
un rappeur à la radio parce que
qu'est ce qu'on fait mais c'est
complètement nous sommes bien s'énonce
comme la radio n'a jamais imposé un
artiste au public oui mais vous jamais
anciens harkis d'accord si un artiste id
ce n'est pas ce que dit le rapport du
sénat sur lui prêtant région du sénat ce
qu'ils connaissent réellement à baltard
ils ont interrogé quand même beaucoup de
gens mais j'étais confiant
posez une décélération enix et duchamp
villon départ la
question monsieur non je ne peux pas
dire quand des jeunes aux familles et
régime critiquent si je peux me
permettre une réflexion tout bête c'est
que le show business en face et du
respect une expression que je prends les
chanteurs et chanteuses c'est comme les
pieds noirs on a toujours besoin avant
les élections après on s'en fout oui
je dirai à mon très rapidement on
élimine le montre avec premièrement 3,10
telle sorte que même jour n'est ce pas
un ne passera jamais le deuxième pas
sera une fois tous les dix jours et le
troisième passera quatre fois par jour
et six en utilisant le même traitement
et est ce que les gens qui ont accepté
et on fait ce passage sont qualifiés
pour le faire cette saison que je pose
je me trompe peut-être deuxièmement pour
répondre à pourrait pour la patrie sauf
qu'à se désole le grand chanteur auteur
compositeur interprète c'est pas une
génération mois pour agace booster un
grand chanteur ozzy osbourne a pas
trente ans et que ce pays soit plus
qu'un son existence ces moments ont
revendiqué dans 30 ans il a fallu trente
ans pour ce pays s'aperçoivent que
justin il appelant le roi qu il allait
faire du rock'n'roll
et juliette juliette gréco pardon
parlons maintenant un petit peu aussi du
rôle de la télévision c'est parce que
non et pas beaucoup parce que la france
en quinze jours quand même on est on a
été quelques conseils dans les quelques
tâches non pas les radios des parades la
scène n'a pas des talents de demain
d'auteurs
connus quand les gens disent la seule
chose que je la seule chose que je peux
je connais moi je sais pas qui c'est les
gens de métier je les connais pas grâce
au ciel et dieu m'en préserve certains
mais vous le faites pour rendre viables
par pour l'amour l'amour l'amour de
travailler alors la mouline à brun
contacté l'amour mais je ne me plains
pas mais vous êtes là tous en train de
vous plaindre je me plais
alors c'est vrai qu'au début on fait de
la chanson pour moi ya ça marche comme
ça dans la chanson il ya quelqu'un qui a
envie un jour de faire de la chanson
daniel paul raconté il a envie de faire
la chanson vous expliquer pourquoi il ya
une vingtaine d'années des gens pour se
sortir d'une condition sociale parce
qu'il ya des gens qui réussissent en un
qui ont des examens qui apprennent un
métier il y en a d'autres qui n'en n'ont
pas et qui pour des raisons sociales
font de la chanson comme il ya des gens
qui ont fait de la boxe
au
pathos
alors qu'il défend léo ferré vous êtes
l'agent de ophélie qui est un énorme
hauteur pour irak après quelque temps un
homme qui regarde y'a forte mauvaise
humeur suis désolé quand monsieur léo
ferré par les chanteurs absar vous vous
étiez plus vous boucher les oreilles ce
pas possible
comme en finlande
grande dame de la chanson que vous
connaissez elle a été matraqué pendant
un an je t'ai son nom elle est passée
sur toutes les antennes elle s'est payé
sa promotion elle a payé tout alors
organisé une tournée en france le nom
elle a quitté paris elle est arrivée au
mans avec toute une troupe dans le nom 0
terminé fini la tournée on a payé tout
le monde des retraits paris dénoncé non
trouvée non vous la connaissez tous deux
s'y trouvent et nous écouter une gamme
qui est matraqué pendant un an son nom
lorsque la
très longue la poche à l'école le temps
roulé par le sida
nettement au départ c'est vrai que
daniel guichard et beaucoup de de gens
qui font les chansons qu'ils ont envie
de faire des listes le fonds pourrait
effectivement sortir un peu de l'univers
dans lequel les villes pour réussir
parce que c'est on fait pas des chansons
va parler d'un studio on sait pas des
disques pour rester inconnu celui qui me
dit qu il fait de la musique pour son
immeuble c'est un menteur donc on le
fait pour être connu pour avancer et
aussi comme certains font de la boxe ou
dotés corrida ou autre chose on essaye
d'avancer certains réussissent et quand
on réussit on se trouve confronté un
système qui n'est plus simplement une
guitare et des chansonnettes c'est un
système totalement structuré qui est
énorme et là on parle de multinationales
mais il faut dire que le monde est
dirigé par trois multinationales
75% du marché au monde appartiennent à
polygram que d'un côté au groupe si
liesse et rca aussi est très important
et on peut pas dire vraiment de mal
c'est pas parce que bob est là parce que
rcr est peut-être étant une maison
américaine celle qui à égalité traite
les produits et françaises et on est
angle oméga et 6 passes en mairie si je
peux me permettre
d'en appeler silence messieurs s'il vous
plaît si je peux d'ailleurs je vous en
prie je peux pas les en laye et la m
eric et non de la chance il faut il faut
considérer aussi que ces trois grands
ces trois grandes puissances de
multinationales à travers à travers le
monde c'est 75% ça veut dire que cette
a8 disque sur disque qui sont vendus
dans le monde appartiennent à ces trois
multinationales en france polydor
phonogrammes barclay des cas tout ça
c'est le même groupe à sourire
maintenant c'est important c'est à dire
que lorsqu'on parle de maurice fanon
quitte une maison pour aller à une autre
on se retrouve dans le l'espèce de folie
que ça appartient à la même maison donc
là on se retrouve dans un poids dans un
gros gros problème qui est qu'elle est
là le gip à l'honnêteté parce qu'il n'y
a pas de malhonnêteté dans les
programmations de radio dès qu'elle est
la puissance elles ont longtemps des
taux les taux d'effets définir les
éléments dérivés à tour il y en a
partout je sais pas la majorité souhaite
en être alloué au film malheureusement
quand on est quand on est producteur de
glee ce distributeur ou éditeur on ne
peut donc difficilement lutter au point
de vue financier sur l'intoxication qui
m'explique vous prenez quelqu'un qui
fait des programmes radio qui
responsable d'une tranche horaire à la
radio qui est pas très anglo américains
à la base vous lui offrez 2 soit un
voyage pour aller quand je dis n'importe
qui disons le au louis ii les ja sont
n'importe qui à los angeles elle faisait
était cette personne dans une conditions
telles qu'elles ses oreilles s'habitue à
la musique américaine je vous certifie
fo troisième voyage elle va vous
embarquent bombardé plein
la peinture du voyage
daniel pourrait revenir à votre cas
particulier parce que vous vous
élargissez le débat mais vous l'élargir
un petit peu le choix c'est vrai
voudrais demander à daniel guichard qui
nous explique un peu son itinéraire on
n'a pas encore demandé vous avez vous
même été pendant un moment dans un trou
j'ai l'impression et vous n'êtes compte
toujours pas très bien du réseau monter
sur les radios périphériques puisque on
m'a dit vous même que vous vous y entend
peu mais c'est vous avez tous les
continents perramant chacun est libre de
penser comme il veut et dire ce qu'il
veut il arrive aussi qu'on sache avec
les gens ça c'est mon problème ça ne
regarde que moi oui mais il est très
cher sur quelles raisons ont des raisons
commerciales
non non non pour désaccord de sur
certaines options par rapport à des gens
dans les endroits non va citer pour la
cité s'est repris mais roy je me suis
accroché avec des gens et ça fait trois
ans que je passe pas et je m'en porte
pas plus mal je suis très heureux oui
parce que c'est un problème c'est une
parenthèse c'est un peu bizarre que ça
soit à cause de démêlés personnel
concerné un champion national en
longueur mais démêler les normes avec
firefox aucune espèce d'importance et
préférons laisser on va finir et que
danic cher ma jiantang est devenu un
business made non le problème c'est
qu'un jour est arrivé pour me mettre
contre un mur de façon un peu l'image et
qu'on me mettre quasiment un couteau
sous la gorge dès qu'on venait on va te
casser le même problème que maurice
fanon procès contre procès j'ai décidé
de ne plus faire de procès je suis
responsable de ce que je fais depuis
huit ans et j'ai décidé une fois pour
toutes de me distribué ça veut dire que
j'ai pris une valise j'ai fait le vrp
pendant un an et demi et j'ai ouvert
aussi la voie avec d'autres gens parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'autres cheminement il
existe deux systèmes
pour cent de la production non j'ai
récupéré tout seul effectivement et g
semble être de grossistes à peu près 1 1
5e de la france et j'espère faire plus
je suis pas tout seul à distribuer parce
qu'effectivement c'est une coïncidence
que il soit là j'espère avoir aussi hugo
fin distribution il ya des tas de gens
que j'espère qu'ils viendront mais le
but de la démarche est simple c'est que
lorsqu'on peut pas faire autrement il
suffit pas rester assis et pleurer ne
faut se lever quand seront effacés
dans dix ans on verra si je suis comme
les os et le foie blast vous ne savez
rien vous pas écouter vous êtes ça vous
avez des problèmes et vous voulez les
résoudre en pleurant agissent et
réagissent est grande entre le président
et une preview les sadc va m'arriver si
vous voulez savoir si vous arrivez à
plaindre avait on peut parler d'autre
chose et que ça fait une heure déjà
comparé que de m'acharner du roct mobile
business si elle rend que j'ai
l'impression que la corse plus de temps
on va y venir
on aurait pu dire encore un peu dans des
multinationales
il faut pas les condamner totalement par
exemple non non
il ya des gens chez eux qui sont les
gens de qualité et deuxièmement temps je
reçois a dit le 6 millions d'heures
qu'ils me disent tu n'es pas
multinationales moi juste un homme qui a
du génie et j'applaudis à ce moment je
me moque de savoir si c'est
une arme et moi julien seri vous en mets
pas permettez que je mène l'émission
comme j'ai envie pas quand vous aimez je
voudrais te dire alors pendant une heure
vous ne parler que du disque l'émission
sera les bienvenus
le spectacle c'est pas les ringards
prétexte une place une étude allemande
heures mais les parties
seraient d'accord particulier de perdre
mon gars je vais vous expliquer comment
se passe un disque
absolument on parle affiché au t4 à mon
ami alors je vous le demande ce qui
s'est produit succès vous gagnez 10 ans
voit jouer les volontaires je suis ne
sais même pas qui vous êtes vous voulez
faire sourire voulez-vous que je
n'excluerais vient poser le manche 2
permettaient romy sont presque est un
jeune juliette gréco juliette gréco
jours et qu'on aborde un peu aussi des
rapports assez l'instant du ringard
mondial dames jeudi de fiches sur les
listes du ragga oui mais vous pouvez
pour ça tu le vends pas d'abo ligne et
bien c'est important quand on fait pas
mal bien je veux lui dire on fait quand
on fait personnes dans une salle du fait
d'un avis d'abord moi je suis producteur
de spectacles quand même j'aime pas du
tout le monde sait que
tu pourrais pas travailler mais c'est ça
des langages aimable et la voix de la
station est stable et la voie de la
blessure du froid rituel vas-y répond
moi qu'est-ce que tu ferais si tu avais
pas les ringards et vous répondez main
mais c'est quoi vous travaillez
transition gars je vais viser c'est je
vais vous répondre je vais vous répondre
mais dans l'ordre non
non non je me suis malade je donne plus
la plante sont julien de réclamer qu'on
parle de la télévision sanaa parce que
dans ce rapport il est reproché à 3,4
producteurs de two monopolisait et que à
cause d'eux il y a une trentaine de
chanteurs qui sont favorisés par rapport
à la masse des autres c'est ça vous avez
reçus une lettre ou d'un producteur de
télévision oui va donner nous aurons
petit texte je vous emmène à molinier
comprendre que j'avais un petit extrait
vous et vous comprendrez que peut-être
que peut-être dans un dans un cas comme
celui-là
ailier des dizaines de personnes de gens
qui font ce métier des ringards comme
absolu comme barbara berberat n'est pas
une ringarde elle fait 3000 personnes
allez allez laissez
vous savez tard oui parler alors voilà
je suis ravi de ce plateau formidable et
à l'arrivée vous en voulez pourquoi
jusqu'en mai dernier
je vais bien entendu
jusqu'en mai dernier s'est passé quelque
chose en mai dernier si vous êtes au
courant j'étais à la caisse jusqu'en mai
dernier je n'avais pas la possibilité et
vous le savez de consacrer des émissions
à certains grands artistes la phase est
président joli non c'est joli à la
rentrée les choses ont changé mais entre
temps je vous avais invité
régulièrement pour prendre contact et ne
pas perdre le contact avec vous vous
avez toujours refusé
alors ça c'est un politique dont on ne
voulait pas donner le nom mais qui fait
une amie qui faisait en tout car et
toutes les semaines une grande émission
de télévision de variété de chansons
écoutées j'ai ce document dans ma main
et je n'ai je ne voulais pas en parler
simplement à la minute où j'ai lu ça je
me suis senti moins triste je vous
comprends oui c'est assez étonnant parce
que cette personne a été chercher que
vous ne pouviez pas passer à la
télévision avant parce que madame grès
quo n'était pas interdit ça lui aurait
fait de la publicité mais n'avait pas
souhaité bon oui nous sommes
quelques-uns comme ça dans ce cas
certains grands interprètes puisqu'il
paraît que c'est comme ça pour une
classe certains grands ringard
interprète
[Musique]
là ce que vous pensez mal an sur ma
femme aille de même source écoutez je
vais vous dire une bonne chose j'ai
toujours pensé de la même manière depuis
très longtemps avec une certaine
progression normale étant donné que je
ne suis pas totalement hariri mental en
tout cas merci j'ai gréco ce petit
témoignages qui confirment un peu ce que
dit le sénat sur le très grave c'est que
c'est signé et que ça existe et que les
gens vous disent vous n'êtes pas passés
à la télévision et quand vous passez
vous vous passez dans la rue de votre
village ou dans la rue dans paris les
gens venise alors vous ne chantez plus
enlevée à bord le problème le problème
du poids que devront départager nous
allons écouter maintenant
nous allons réparer avec les sens un peu
du rock'n'roll puisqu'on va parler de
soi sont aujourd'hui
aimable à raison comme
si là aussi c'est
la question n'est pas n'est pas de faire
plaisir aux jeunes qui rêvait oui mais
la question qu'on s'ouvre à
nous sourire et une bassine les oreilles
depuis bientôt une heure et demie sur la
question des grands compositeurs et les
grands artistes français
j'ai eu la bêtise de prétendre qu'il
existe maintenant une nouvelle race de
chanteurs et de compositeurs français
qui font du rock 'n' roll ou de la
musique qui est fortement influencée par
le canal presque que chez ces gens là on
trouve la plus grande force peut-être
d'écriture de des années 80 de la fin de
ce siècle sont les groupes comme
starshooter sondés qu'aucun téléphone ce
sont trois des gens qui vendent 400
mille albums et qu'il faut 5,6 me la
personne quand ils passent dans des
villes de province cet axe gorge dit
olivier coppens qui s'est énormément de
gens qui ne partent pas sur les antennes
de la télévision ou très rarement sur
les antennes des ondes pour la bonne
raison qu une station périphérique à
exactement six heures de radio de
musique par jour ce radio le reste étant
pris par les jeux les annonces
l'accordéon la chanson française
[Musique]
on est déjà mais c'est déjà la couleur
et higuain il ya des chanteurs et des
stars de gros et les grands et les
nouveaux les nouveaux auteurs
compositeurs ils sont là et christiane
et les attaques et vient de là ils
savent y vient de là et d'autres
d'autres centaines de personnes leur vie
se passe en ce moment et effectivement
il ya eu le problème et les
multinationales qui était fermé à ce mec
là et des radios qui sont fermés
toujours à la création de ces gens là
sauf que l'écriture elle est là le
nouveau langage les la dent fodé il faut
des gens comme michelin qui arrive avoir
40 ans pour qu'on entende tout type de
langage mais les types qui ont 20 ans 18
ans 25 ans qui sont les les créateurs de
ce nouveau langage ou est ce qu'on les
voit on les voit michel drucker enfants
on les voir dans les bois patrick pour
les voir et pour les accueillir nous et
on ne les entend pas il y a un des taux
maintenant depuis l'élection de françois
mitterrand il ya un nouveau ghetto le
samedi après midi sur la première chaîne
alors on les trouve tous ensemble
effectivement les gens vont être
mécontents ont les fours tous ensemble
samedi après midi oui ou le jeudi soir
sur la deuxième chaîne mais ce sont les
artistes à part entière pourquoi est-ce
que vous n'êtes pas chaud avec des
vertus de roquebrun je vous devenez
labeaume yéniches thierry augier et rio
chant et maintenant laissez moi vous
faire écouter un groupe qui n'a pas
encore eu une la chance nick passe à la
radio ni à la télévision et qui nous
prépare un disque mais qui n'a pas
encore pu faire un disque je crois que
philippe constantin n'a fait le disque
effet si c'est un groupe de lyon et ce
groupe a un intérêt particulier je crois
que c'est le sol c'est en tout cas le
premier c'est un groupe qui est un
groupe de rock arabe composée de deux
marocains deux algériens français voici
gars y aura six cartes de séjour car de
césure à vous
[Musique]
le
non
[Musique]
niamey
non
[Musique]
m
car
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les
[Musique]
non
et vous
m nous
mathieu briand
[Musique]
j'aurais peut-être dire amants terribles
et m'avait rameau aimable oui je peux
dire à moi parce que tout à l'heure le
gars il m'a dit qu'il m'avait jamais
entendu oui mais moi tant qu'ils feront
de la musique comme ça je peux encore
lui 40 ans merci à madame souligné
madame e ligne et crois pas que c'est
mieux comme un géant bancaire mais
pourquoi venir un oui encore des propos
reste à écouter
et voir ce qu'on voulait c'est
formidable
attendez ffi après je réalise que chaque
artiste chaque maison sinon s'il vous
plaît il faudrait s'attaquer
à l'eau moi ce que je peux sauter sans
charisme
ce que je voudrais bien la journée une
prison ne prennent le
temps d'écouter whisky je ne suis pas
quelqu'un de connu non mais je n'ai pas
tout donné par l'action monsieur que la
thur d'époque de seconde j'étais venu
j'ai demandé de devenir de lyon je
connais bien carte de séjour et
j'apprécie parce que monsieur a dit là
bas parce que c'est dégueulasse et
j'espère que deux on va essayer de
changer ça il ne chante pas en anglais
ils ont leur langue ils ont grandi ici
et ils ont raison henri dévier sur une
musique l'horreur on sait pas fini
[Applaudissements]
on
parle d'affairé de plein de gens c'est
vrai moi je chante dans la rue depuis
bientôt huit ans je viens de refuser un
contrat chez rca parce qu'on te 6% de
royalties quelqu'un il
attendait de 950 mhz elle est levée j'ai
produit mon risque tout seul il vient de
sortir je me suis complètement défoncés
pour trouver sage emprunté de partout je
me bats dans la rue pour la chanson je
demande que la chanson de rue et le
droit de réponse il ya des gens qui
vivent de la rue tue ceux embarqués tous
les jours j'ai pris trois modes prison
parce que je chantais dans les rues mais
quand j'entendais pour toi tu pars de la
chanson soul se mouiller j'ai envie que
les et j'ai pas bu du whisky comprenez
le ce qui change c'est la révolution
c'est la vie c'est ce qui le demandent
ils ont raison je suis pour le rock pour
toutes les expressions et je ne fais pas
du rock c'est docly vous pourrez pas
nous l'enlever bravo quand j'étais bien
parce que vous pouvez pas comprendre
c'est tout ce que j'avais à dire et je
crois d'avancé de nous alors très bien
où les samedis ce milieu
rural et financier du système qu'ils
viennent en face ils ne pourront plus
parler parce qu'on a des tripes voilà ce
qu'on crève vraiment et qu'on s'en fout
des run run c'est la fête et la vie ou à
la mairie qualité pour tous rôle tu nous
as tu un soutien merci fiba
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a commencé de manda parent alors et
perrin qui vont la parole
dans 5 minutes simplement sur les
antennes on vous téléphone comme c'était
le cas pour ma chanson oui on leur
demande rien entendre ça oui alors
qu'ils fassent des fois les
démolitions
sont les jeux gendre et les chants les
chances qu'ils soient tous les meilleurs
des
ffi
qu'il n'y a que des ringards d'un côté
que des bons de l'autre est complètement
ridicule de le penser d'une part parce
que ces départs ya beaucoup d'artistes
que la city que j'apprécie effectivement
beaucoup aussi mais moi ma forme
expression en moi c'est le rock'n'roll
effectivement comme eux mais pourtant
comme chaque artiste qui est ici que ce
soit du rop autre chose qu'on sait de
musique on a chacun une façon différente
on est chacun en cas particulier et
c'est là le grand problème du show
business c'est que chaque fois on est
tous des cas particuliers par pour ce
genre de truc c'est que c'est une
question de goût les certains trucs
certains mecs qui m'ont trouvé ça super
et c'est très bien comme ça et d'autres
mais qui trouveront ça complètement naze
et puis c'est tout le showbiz on peut
parler pendant des heures on puisse
jamais lundi durant le point c'est tout
alors ça sert à rien discuté pendant des
heures parce que depuis dix ans tandis
que des cas particuliers
on n'a pas vraiment parlé du show
business et en plus on envisager aucune
solution
alors oui
on est les rejeter aussi bien niveau
social à tous les niveaux alors on
essaye de pouvoir s'exprimer dans notre
langue dans le rock'n'roll et de pouvoir
faire connaître aux gens qu'il n'y a pas
des délinquants dans la race arabe en
france et que il ya des gens qui peuvent
souffrir à travailler leurs instruments
moi je travaille quatre 4 heures par
jour mon instrument bon c'est comme ça à
travailler sa voix travail et sa guitare
pour pouvoir s'exprimer dans un autre
domaine et que j'aimerais que la presse
française en général ne
j'aimerais que la presse française en
général ne misent toujours pas sur les
histoires de délinquance
côté négatif je connais des je connais
des peintres je connais des musiciens je
connais des médecins je connais des tas
de personnes arabe qui essayent de
s'exprimer en france qu'on rejette alors
nous ce qu'on veut faire c'est
s'exprimer dans ce qu'on sait faire
c'est-à-dire la musique on veut montrer
qu'il n'ya pas les autochtones qui
peuvent perdre la bonne musique et qui
peut s'exprimer pardon quand même les
plus vieilles civilisations ça il y
avait inventé beaucoup de choses entre
plantes non mais un dernier mot aussi
puisqu'on parle de pas mal de maisons de
disques en parle entre autres de deux
des grands médias on a été visité les
maisons de disques bon on va vous dire
comment ça s'est passé la première fois
je vais pas cacher le nom de la boîte on
a été voir c'était si ps bon alors on
arrive c'est un grand building c'est
super beau on voit qu'il est pas mal de
blé quand même rendre dans un bureau on
arrive c'est environ 10 d'attendre la
personne qui doit écouter la musique
alors présente la cassette il ya coup le
chien et laufen maria est désolé faut
être franc c'est en fait y'a pas mal
alors le type il écoute la caisse est
pendante je sais pas moi disons 10
secondes et dit qu'il a écouté tous les
trucs
tiens j'ai pas apportées il bouffe et
les déboires bonne et je suis gay mais
tout est à la fin de la cassette u10a
c'est bien dommage le type qui s'occupe
des la musique folklorique il est pas là
alors
là
bon moi je voudrais dire puisqu'on peut
parler du rock au moins une minute dans
tout ça ça veut dire que tous les mômes
qui veulent père du rock
les trois quarts ils ont pas une thune
alors vous préférez les boire avec des
flingues avec de la dope ou alors avec
des instruments de musique alors aidez
les enlever les taxes sur les
instruments de musique à 33% de luxe
nous on a pas utile quand on est chassé
le show-business aussi quand tu veux
jouer quand tu veux jouer il faut que tu
paye très cher ton instrument ou tu
trouves le pognon tu veux qu'on aille à
la rue braquer des banques alors si vos
coups durs seraient personnes qui savent
aller aider les membres qui n'ont pas
jeté qui veulent mettre leur expression
simplement il est encore dans des villes
et j'ai alors et de l'étoile
[Applaudissements]
téléphone en redemande dégoûté de groupe
mais là nous n'aurons pas de rasseoir
l'envié est choisi
avec le chiffre est il faudrait être
correct à petit on va être honnête parce
que nous on soit la jeune génération du
rock n roll c'est une chose parce qu'on
a beaucoup mais il ya aussi des gens qui
ont 50 et 60 et qui n'aime pas
particulièrement requins ans qui veut
pas dire soit pas l'aimer mais quand on
passe je veux pas être sectaire mais
quand on passe depuis le début de
l'après midi jusqu'à la fin on a parlé
beaucoup du rock'n'roll alors parlons
des autres
quant à eux mêmes
bonjour me nativel séculaire on avait le
sourire la salle non mais bon ce soir
monsieur
suppôts la clé ce qui laisse supposer il
y à des milliers d'associations france
qui organise les spectacles et on n'en
parlait pas aujourd'hui oui vous pouvez
faire un super lap s'il vous plaît qu'on
pouvait comprendre la 4e journée avoir
l'impression non écoutez monsieur al
games se vante dans tous les champions
ce complexe temps pris par les potes sur
d'aussi plumelec souplet patrice blanc
francard n'a pas pas placer un mot ce
soir avec quiconque lui parce qu'il m'a
semblé non mais écoutez on n'a jamais
parlé du thé l'avion ce même un noyau
maintenant on attend les grèves s'il
vous plaît on avance le nom et leur gré
à la discothèque oscillations vous
n'avez parlé que du 10 leur gré des
building veille a divorcé de lombez les
flowlines et je ne me doutais parce que
j'étais major j'ai effectivement
stellaire non
monsieur pas la laïcité
c'est formidable quand je voudrais
signaler l'excellent halimi et 10 chargé
d'un lourd silence
petit rang peut dire quelque chose y
aller si vous pouvez voudrais signaler
que sur ce plateau ce soir sont tenues
des invités qui ont chacun le droit
d'amener un invité qui se teignent est
assis dans le fond de la salle j'aurais
voulu que ces gens respectent un peu
l'émission autrement nous naviguerons
plus les gens que sur l'émission mais ça
ça m'est égal vous n'aurez ce métier pas
le moment vous vous taisez voilà alors
je voudrais quand même pas
je savais que madame molinier qui est
venu là soir elle va finir par le
regretter
non mais je vous comprends bien
on a réalisé ce qu'on dit à chaque
émission alors silence voilà c'est ce
qu'on dit à chaque échelon 6 mois on
pourrait peut-être dire des choses
concrètes des machines à
laver par les bataillons des
responsabilités je pense que le fond du
poème dans le showbiz mal et on le sort
de monsieur m'a alors nous alors
je regrette que les que les invités mais
menez des éleveurs
[Musique]
et je vais vous faire écouter chance aux
chefs de chantiers davie est champion
car si la fin les cellules a
envoyé le générique de fin c'est couper
l'image parce que c'est vraiment pas
plaisant ouais mais tu es le le
générique de fin avec la chanson de nlhe
à colombes
voilà mettez la chance de nous équiper
l'antenne en couple antennes et je
m'excuse mais les téléspectateurs
toi
arrêté mettant
leblanc
m
[Musique]